hey guys Ryan right in the hizzy so
today I'm gonna be talking about
daredevil episode 2 I'm loving the way
this show is going I saw the second
episode last night I loved it even more
than the first one from the beginning of
the episode was he daredevil he's
injured he's laying in a dumpster
rosario dawson plays Claire Claire is a
nurse and she's healing daredevil she's
the first one next to uh I think the
guy's name is Jose to actually see Matt
Murdock his whole face and everything
and she's helping him I really like the
way this episode was executed it was
done in a very subtle way really
tension-filled the whole time
I like the B story in it how it cuts
back and forth between Matt Murdock as
daredevil trying to find out the
information of where this little boy was
kidnapped at the same time it's coming
back to where he was a little boy in his
last memories with his father at first I
wasn't actually interested in the stuff
with his father as the story progressed
I became more and more interested I
really liked the guy plays his dad what
I really like about the story with his
dad is it's really felt the impact of
why he became daredevil and a lot of
these stories you know you see something
happening like some personal life trauma
usually someone in the family dies due
to crime and then they become a hero so
I've seen that done before a billion
times but it's rare where I actually
felt like because you see that his dad
was involved with the mob and that he
won a fight just to make his son proud
you know so they could chant Jack in the
crowd that really was touching and it
sucks that he died but you see in that
moment right then and there of why he
became daredevil and you actually really
feel it that's basically my main
emphasis on it is that normally you
logically understand it's rare where
you're like I really feel like this guy
should become daredevil to get justice
you know there's some really memorable
stuff in this episode
I love how far this shows willing to go
in terms of violence like yes it's
Marvel but Marvel's very much aware that
daredevil is a violent comic book I love
that moment where he can smell the
guy coming through all the way from like
down on the third floor that moment
where he takes the fire extinguisher and
drops it you know it's cool because we
saw daredevil in episode 1 already but
he's still rather mysterious his
interaction with Claire is great I like
the friendship that's formed here this
level of understanding how she's a nurse
hearing about that daredevil is out
there and how she helps him everyone was
telling me like okay Ryan if you thought
the first episode was brutal wait till
you get to the second one yeah that
moment was pretty damn disturbing Hugh
and Claire's like used a knife to
penetrate the nerve right above here and
they went for it I felt like he was
gonna get close and then the guy was
gonna be like okay I'll tell you I'll
tell you but then he actually stabs him
and puts the knife right above his eye I
think it worked I think it did the job
when he was hanging him off the rooftop
when daredevil throws him off the roof I
did want the guy to die I would like to
see it where a hero is willing to kill
people you know I don't know if that's
like part of Daredevils code to kill or
not to kill but it seemed like daredevil
intended to kill him it doesn't seem
like it seemed like the guy lived by
chance and I like that moon because she
asked him is he gonna be alive and he
actually takes time to hear the guy's
heartbeat to see if he is still
breathing
and he says yeah he's gonna be fine but
was daredevil really planning on letting
the guy live or did he intend to kill
him it wasn't my favorite part of the
show but I did enjoy the character
moments between Karen and foggy when
they're going bar-hopping a part of me
was like didn't she just go through like
some horrible traumatic stuff and
doesn't it feel a little dangerous for
her to be out so late at night
especially in Hell's Kitchen
like I thought some people might still
be after her but apparently it was fine
for them and I like that bonding moment
I like how this show wasn't all about
just being dark and serious like they
took the time to actually let it be fun
with these characters and what I really
like about daredevil too is his voice a
lot of the time in video games and
action movies everyone tries to [ __ ]
sound like that man but he just has his
regular voice when he's daredevil he
still sounds menace
but he's not putting on some like smoker
accent he's he just has his New York
accent but he's still intimidating and
he's great in the role man like he just
gets cooler and I'm wondering if it is
Charlie Cox is doing a lot of the stunts
how the [ __ ] can you walk away like you
could watch this whole episode and be
bored I don't care but when you get to
the last 10 minutes that is some of the
best shot stuff I've ever seen film or
television it's all in one take it's all
panning around you see the two rooms you
see the hallway
daredevil shows up it's still continuing
in one shot and then it does this whole
[ __ ] fight scene
I love the fight because daredevil he's
so injured and the performance of the
fight scene was great too because it
wasn't like oh just act injured like he
really seemed like he was injured but
kept persisting kept going you could
feel the cause inside of him to win you
could feel the motivation and the fight
itself was really cool it's not like
necessarily the most stylistic fight
what I loved about the fight scenes in
this is that a there's actual fight
scenes in this show like I said before a
lot of shows of try doing fight scenes
never have I seen them pulled off this
well and I like how its stylish yes but
it's also like realistically brutal at
the same time he's a martial artist but
he's also like you see that as punches
or that of a boxer it's really detailed
in the style of the fighting and it
really does add to his character that's
what I like about the fighting style of
this is that the fighting style
perfectly matches the tone of the show
the daredevil character it all perfectly
fits and then he saves the boy in the
end and you're like yeah that's [ __ ]
daredevil I [ __ ] love it and it just
hooks you in you just want to keep
watching more like I've only seen two
episodes now but first one I did I was
like I gotta check out more the more and
then this one had it now I'm like that's
it I gotta just start binge watching the
[ __ ] out of this as soon as possible
well yeah that's my review on daredevil
episode 2 rating time dare devil takes
Netflix to the next level
rhyming ratings anyway guys thanks for
telling me about Daredevils so excited
to be watching this show if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter we have a
vine we don't really use it there's a
Pinterest someone created for us we
don't use it but follow us on there as
well because it makes us look cooler
crime is happening outside